behörden entdecken drogen tunnel von
mexiko in die usa im kampf gegen das
organisierte verbrechen finden us beamte
einen tunnel der offenbar zum
drogenschmuggel im großen stil verwendet
wurde hunderte meter führt der
unterirdischen geheimgang von einem
unscheinbaren haus in der mexikanischen
stadt tijuana nach nauheim esa im
kalifornischen san diego
die wände sind verstärkt am boden liegen
schien außerdem ist der tunnel mit einem
belüftungssystem und strom ausgestattet
laut den behörden stießen die beamten
auf den drogen tunnel bei der ermittlung
gegen sechs drogendealer die sich
offenbar auf diesem wege mit kokain
versorgt haben bei der festnahme seien
800 kilogramm kokain 75 kilogramm und
106 kilogramm heroin beschlagnahmt
worden
das entspricht einem marktwert von über
drei millionen dollar wie viele drogen
auf dieser unterirdischen drogen rote
unterschlagen wurden kann man nur
erahnen
zu welchem drogenkartell der tunnel
gehören könnte wurde nicht
bekanntgegeben
nach us bundesrecht muss der tunnel nun
mit beton aufgefüllt werden ist dahin
wird der kleine schacht der in den
tunnel hinab führt von schwerbewaffneten
spezialkräften bewacht